okay but like i want to know right it's
having how how you've done youtube for
how long would you say now like the
beginning of youtube since the beginning
but
okay as a as a job full-time job as a
full-time youtuber how are you doing
yeah you're a little over a year and a
half year and a half two years okay
so like i because i always ask people
who like kind of come into the whole
full-time youtube thing like
as of recently right because like being
a full-time youtuber
now is completely different to like
being a full-time youtuber
like when god became full-time yeah yeah
so like as someone who's been there from
the beginning of youtube
how would you say it's like changed as a
full-time thing
as opposed to like just doing it as a
hobby i think definitely like it's more
profitable now obviously back then at
the beginning i mean it's not like i'm
not saying like you're rolling in it by
any means like your guts like like
none of my videos are monetized
i can't really complain about that tell
me the video where you reviewed the
[ __ ] of the round table wasn't
monetized are you saying this episode
are you saying sponsored yes if if not
for patreon and sponsors you just
wouldn't have a job but you're getting
out there though and that's like that's
the important
thing right yeah and then if you get
like if people watch you then people are
gonna be like
[ __ ] let's get this [ __ ] to advertise
our [ __ ] [ __ ] right and then
that's i mean definitely it's like back
in the monetary days when youtube wasn't
so
pissy i think it was bound to happen
yeah it was about of course like
i don't know it was gonna
i wonder because like back then i almost
think for me like youtube was as much of
like a social thing for me as it matches
like i enjoyed making the videos it was
more about like
what a cause it was the same with voice
acting for me well the the major reason
i
i kept doing voice acting and i liked it
so much is that it was like how i
socialized with those people
yeah and i almost felt like youtube was
an extension of that where half the time
which is why you know when we said in
ages ago when i was like they're only
making videos for each other et cetera
et cetera because
i remember when i did it like when you
first start you kind of do
make videos in a sense for your peers
and for like to
impress one because it's a very social
thing when you're smaller because
there's no pressure
yeah right it's like i just want to make
videos my mate made a really cool video
i want to make a cool video to like yeah
you're just [ __ ] around
with your friends right right right and
half the funny like what i thought was
funny at the time probably not funny at
all yeah
the stuff i made was because i'm like
dude my friends are gonna [ __ ] love
this
yeah they left their ass off right
that's why i made it half the time
and i feel like that's that aspect
pretty much goes
instantly when you start doing it full
time yeah you still do make friends
obviously you know we're all youtubers
and friends but
the aspect of making videos for like a
social purpose completely goes
yeah i find yeah yeah i mean i i'd still
say i do kind of make videos for social
purposes because
it's it's still like technically because
you're talking about current topics a
lot
yeah i mean and there's also like i i
when we talk about youtube i see youtube
now
as like i just make youtube for like a
general audience not just like an anime
watching audience so
like there are a lot of other youtubers
out there who have to do things that are
like
have nothing to do with anime but i
still respect their content
and like it's the best [ __ ] feeling
when there's you meet a guy
or a guy or a girl who has nothing to do
with your community
and you find out that watch your content
and you're like i love your stuff yeah
i'm like
wait a minute i love your stuff too
everybody class did we just become best
friends
that's the best moment because you're
like yeah we're gonna hang out right
yeah oh yeah we are yeah
we're gonna hang out we're not gonna
make a video to hang out just get a
chill yeah
no you know you found a good like new
youtuber friend when you meet for the
first time and
the word collab just isn't said for like
five more times
yeah like like you don't even take a
selfie together no yeah yeah
you just know each other's like essence
the worst i [ __ ] the biggest thing i
hate is when a
someone is like hey let's collab and i'm
like all right what do you have in mind
i don't know just want to collab
and i'm like can you come with like an
idea or something like
i don't want to do the work if it's your
collab yeah like i i can't stand it like
just collab let's just do it
like what what do you want to do tell me
what you want so easy to do collab
i can't think of my own videos what
makes you think i'm going to help you
with yours yeah exactly
sorry i'm angry i just had so many
moments where that happens
you came in with a bit of a chip on your
shoulder
[Laughter]
i guess i do so like how long do you
think like currently because like i
assume you want to like continue to like
evolve your content in some
ways right definitely i i definitely
don't as much as it probably pains
some people to hear i don't want to just
stick with hentai i want because you
know i
i'm i have other things i like to do i'm
not some nympho maniac as many people
have
alluded to yeah well what are people's
like assumption on you based on your
content
a lot of people have actually asked me
it's like do you just like have sex all
the time do you just read sex is that
all you [ __ ] do and i was like why
would you think that
there are people who do what what would
you do
whatever would make you think in the
morning okay it's like
to you is it like it's hentai now has
your relationship with like hentai
changed because we were talking last
week about how our relationship with
anime has changed because
even though we still very much enjoy it
it is part of the job as well yeah
if anything i would say like my
knowledge and just like appreciation of
it has grown deeper
and just like kind of like it's more
like i i
never really changed too deep i would
say like in terms of like
enjoying it as sort of a hobby now it's
just kind of like just reading it not
even just for like
to get horny or just like enjoy it the
last thing i want
is like i'm mid wank and i'm thinking
this is going to make a great video
like that's the thing right like do you
ever get to the point where you're just
reading a doji and
you're like in the back of your mind
you're like i could just read this
or i need to be reading this because
that actually kind of that does suck
because it's like sometimes you're just
like okay
all right i'm i might i don't want to
ruin porn
yeah not that i'm fond of it anyway i
just don't want to form an attachment